whoa look who it is what brings you here
I know
Eliza's is not the last we are going to
see of you this season we see in the
trailer you confronting Patricia what
can you tell me about the choice to go
to that event and to do the things you
did well I mean I thought once again we
don't have to lose I already just you
know put my foot in my mouth at the last
party it's at this point I'm gonna I'm
going to look I'm gonna let them
remember me I'm gonna go down I might as
well just have some fun with this this
is what I was thinking no that's that's
not it's not exactly what I was thinking
again I went into it thinking that maybe
there's a chance if and when it goes on
too long you know if you have to give an
ultimatum so be it Patricia all right we
had a good relationship right only a few
days a person went on Catherine's side
here we were we talked a few hours on
the phone we shot it she was trying to
get me to troll Catherine and do some
things that do her dirty work
Patsy insist upon us merging my mother
in a reputation with some conspiracy
theories
none are true I think you're a bit
delusional same-same and she's made my
life a living hell with you when I
called her out on it I tried to tell her
on the phone she thought I was
ridiculous for saying it and some other
things transpired and I didn't do it the
right way but I went to the press and
she felt so attacked by that and she
made from that point on she made my life
a living hell she made my life a living
hell and all of a sudden catherine was
her best friend
I remember thinking if she does allow me
to pull it aside and talk to her and she
treats me with you know shows some grace
some you know she's she's kind towards
me she could make me feel like an idiot
she's gonna blow my mind first of all
and I'm gonna feel like the [ __ ] I'm
gonna feel I'm gonna feel like the silly
one and I'm gonna walk away with my tail
between my legs that's what I was hoping
was that she's just gonna blow my mind
and I'm like I lost a good person in my
life that's really what I was hoping I
wanted her to kind of you know kind of
what's the word make me teach me a
lesson really she didn't she she was
everything I expected can you push me so
hard
yeah I'm calling the cops it appears you
get thrown out yeah that event was that
kind of when you knew you were done with
Charleston oh yeah yes and I got up to
the party and I thought no don't do it
don't do it what are you doing why are
you just a glutton for punishment
stop and then I had that what if and I
can tell you I mean again it was just a
blur because I walked in that party and
I thought it could go either way and I
saw her and I beelined it towards her
and for a second she gave me a look
I said Patricia can I talk to you she
gave me a look she turn around and I
thought she was gonna tell her guests
excuse me no I'll just leave it at that
yeah Oh No so and then in that moment I
thought you know what you know I would
like that
next it gave me some closure okay yes I
tried to find peace in that I did the
best that I could do but I mean I still
get myself in trouble I still put my
foot in my mouth all the time can just
see how I talk I just yes yes so I wish
people like understood that I regret
showing up that day at Eliza's and
regret showing up at this party we're
gonna see or are you happy you did it oh
my goodness
I need to say you know regret I'm glad
he did it cuz I can look back and say no
I tried I wish it would have gone
differently but I really think that I
didn't have a chance and I think that's
the best way to put it
okay yes I really didn't have a chance
to make it right there's just no way I
everyone was you know they wanted they
wanted their chance to go after me
and make themselves relevant and you
know I get it I get it you know they're
just I'm the one that everyone's talking
about and they want I get it I get it so
yeah I just I didn't have a chance
I really did